confrontation de points de vue ce soir
entre laurent joffrin et ambroise
méchant on va s'arrêter sur différents
sujets politiques et on va commencer par
analyser ce qui se passe en paca il ya
des suites à la sphère muselier le
président sortant a déposé sa liste ce
matin il figure bien des membres de la
république en marche même s'il y a un
ministre ni parlementaire on pourrait
alors croire que le dossier est réglé
mais non la polémique semble avoir eu un
impact sur les intentions de vote avant
d'en parler avec nos invités le détail
avec et guillaume bertrand
le rassemblement national devant les
républicains au premier tour en région
paca et ce quoi qu'il arrive
ce sont les conclusions de deux sondages
parus cette semaine dans ce premier cas
de figure la liste rn2 thierry mariani
devance les républicains lrm n'arrive
qu'en quatrième position
ici en cas d'alliance avec la république
en marche la liste l air est toujours 2e
derrière le rassemblement national qui
obtient 38 % des voix
renaud muselier le candidat des
républicains déplorent les mauvaises
circonstances du sondage on se retrouve
dans une situation ce sondage a été fait
dans le pire des moments pour moi une un
psychodrame dramatique pour elle est à
haut niveau national puisse plus
l'assassinât du policier avignon et donc
forcément vous avez une crise et au
niveau national du front national entre
deux trois points ici dans cette région
très sensible de près de 5 points
pourtant c'est bien christian estrosi
qui sera tête de liste dans les
alpes-maritimes le même qui avait claqué
la porte du parti des républicains il ya
une semaine et ainsi participer aux
conflits internes face à la possibilité
de voir le rn triompher le président
sortant persiste dans sa politique
d'ouverture et de l'agir du modem 2
élu de la rvm c'est pas les immigrés les
roms
finalement il n'y a pas de ministre il
n'y a pas de parlementaire avec cette
phrase renaud muselier exclut donc la
candidate lrm sophie cluzel secrétaire
d'état chargé des personnes handicapées
en revanche aucun des deux candidats n'a
écarté l'hypothèse d'une alliance au
second tour et avec nous donc pour ce
match des idées ce soir laurent joffrin
bienvenue vous êtes fondateur et
président du mouvement engageons nous
pour le rassemblement de la gauche
sociale écologique et républicaine face
à vous ambroise mais jean bienvenue vous
êtes délégué général des jeunes avec
macro et tête de liste en ardèche merci
à tous les deux d'être avec nous laurent
joffrin parlons d'abord de ce sondage
qui donne le candidat et rennes thierry
mariani vainqueur en paca dans tous les
cas ça veut dire très clairement que le
rn sort renforcée de cette séquence de
ce psychodrame auquel on a assisté
quelques jours selon toute apparence oui
parce que une espèce de combinaison
qu'il essayait de se mettre en place qui
est en cours en cours et ça fait
manoeuvre c'est fait comment dire
combinazione comme on dit en italie gens
que c'est pas ça donne une mauvaise
image des partis dits de gouvernement
donc je vous le front de libération
nationale continue sa route comme une
force tranquille n'est pas plus surpris
que cela par la réaction des potentiels
électeurs en paca en paca il est déjà
très fort de toute façon il était déjà
fort la fois d'avant il le sera cette
fois ci et je crains parce que chaque
jour qui passe leur enfant sains les
erreurs commises par les les deux
parties en question d'une feinte et puis
évidemment voyez des assassinats de
policiers ou des actes terroristes le
discours sécuritaire à sécuritaire du du
rassemblement national porte sur une
partie du lectorat donc c'est un vrai
danger est maintenant embrase méjean
vous êtes mettez des erreurs dans votre
camp politique sur cet épisode avec avec
renaud muselier part je pense qu'on peut
que déplorer le spectacle qui a été
donné la semaine dernière par ce que il
y avait au départ il faut rappeler
l'historique qu'est ce qui s'est passé
renaud muselier a tendu la main il a dit
je souhaite faire une liste de large
rassemblement le premier ministre dans
le jdd a répondu à cet appel il a dit
très bien nous sommes d'accord pour
travailler avec vous dès le premier tour
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé juste après
le bureau national des républicains qui
apparemment aujourd'hui préfèrent
considérer qu'on peut mieux travailler
quand on est républicain avec le
rassemblement national carrick la
république en marche a fait le choix de
mettre la pression sur renaud muselier
qui a dû en quelque sorte revenir en
arrière vous c est l'air qui a sur réagi
mais c'est pas jean castex qui a mal
joué son coup avec jean castex n'a fait
que répondre à la demande nous verra son
allure à carreaux noirs agaçante dans un
grand journal du week end
castex il a quand même officialiser le
fait que l hérault m est un parti de
droite comme les autres puisque il
estime naturel génialement d'aller avec
muselier vous savez et donc pas du tout
avec les autres et cc c'est un problème
parce que 2e en paca au deuxième tour
s'il est si les pourcentages sont de
vrais les mêmes que ceux qui donnent les
sondages on se retrouve dans la
configuration de la fois d'avant et la
fois d'avant la droite a gagné parce que
la gauche sortirait donc s'arrête le
même problème là le sort de cette région
donc la victoire éventuelle du
rassemblement national va tenir au
comportement des électeurs de gauche
alors si si si tout le monde se met à
droite ce quelqu'un mais puisque tout le
monde va se mettre sur la même liste
avec du riz des designers d'aujourd'hui
est encore qu'au cul ouais on est obligé
de sortir et où enfin nous nos candidats
ce concours klein a voté se retire et
nous on est con on est convié à aller
voter pour la droite contrôler sa mort
at comme d'hab ça passe de plus en plus
mal c'est vrai que c'est nous fans ou
les gens responsables y avait évidemment
il vaut mieux que ce soit la droite
plutôt que sa droite entre deux maux ont
choisi le moindre mais et les électeurs
vont se faire avoir
oui à titre personnel je considère que
de toute façon la clarté politique
aurait voulu que l'offre soit la plus
grande possible au premier tour c'est à
dire que il y aurait eu plus de logique
à faire ce rassemblement soir du premier
tour a expliqué que face au
rassemblement national il ya la
nécessité de se rassembler de ne pas
abandonner la région je constate que ce
n'est pas le cas et je peut que le
déplorer ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est
que
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de cette
alliance ce dont ne parle pas assez du
candidat du rassemblement national qui
est en jeu dans cette élection thierry
mariani c'est un ancien cadre des
républicains mais c'est surtout
quelqu'un qui a montré par le passé
qu'il n'en avait pas grand chose à faire
de la région paca il a siégé entre 2004
et 2010 j'ai retrouvé un article de
presse qui faisait qu'il a siégé sept
fois sur 32 assemblée plénière de la
région est donc là encore on a un
exemple parfait de ce qu'est le
rassemblement national où le front
national
quelqu'un qui n'en n'a absolument rien à
faire de la région où il est candidat
mais qui bénéficie des erreurs qui sont
commises par d'autres et je pense qu'il
faut le déplorer en attendant il est en
tête dans les sondages et vous avez
peut-être lu cette interview de
christian jacob ce matin dans le
parisien qui nous dit le premier
ministre devient le meilleur carburant
du r n comment vous prenez ça je trouve
que c'est assez déplorable quand on
regarde que ce que ce que font les
républicains concrètement sur le terrain
parce que il s'agit pas de mots il
s'agit de fait les républicains c'est le
parti qui aujourd'hui bénéficie du
soutien du rassemblement national dans
le tarn et garonne pour 2 2 quand on
l'est républicain c'est le parti qui
fait alliance avec nicolas dupont aignan
en bourgogne franche comté dont il faut
rappeler qu'il était quand même le
premier ministre putatif de marine le
pen donc les leçons de morale de
christian jacob qui n'est incapable de
tenir ses troupes
elles sont quand même mal placé le
gouvernement ils luttent contre le
rassemblement national par des actes et
par des faits pas par des mots
laurent joffrin on a beaucoup dit à un
moment donné que françois mitterrand
avait un peu joué à faire monter le
rassemblement national c'est une petite
musique on est en train d'entendre à
propos de la majorité présidentielle
aujourd'hui de ce que ferait emmanuel
macron et la macro ni autour du allen le
faire monter en étant sûr à la fin de le
battre est ce que la comparaison vous
semble lui répondre sur mitterrand
d'abord c'est pas tout à fait faux selon
ses calculs mais je crois pas que ce
soit lui qui ait annoncé qu'elle remue
le front national à l'époque c'est la
situation du pays des difficultés
rencontrées par une partie des classes
populaires notamment les quartiers le
plus pur c'était ce qui se passait à
dreux par exemple à l'époque c'était en
temps mais ça faisait partie
si on divise la droite et l'extrême
droite ça nous est enfin assez favorable
mais qu'est ce qu'il fallait qu'il fasse
et il est lui il a essayé aussi par sa
politique de montrer qu'il allait dans
le sens de l'intérêt des salariés de
france on est en train de prêter le même
calcul à emmanuel macron oui là c'est
pousser pas exactement la même chose en
plus mitterrand a dit mais attendez le
front national fait 10 où je peux à
l'époque 15%
c'est bizarre on le voit jamais à la
télé donc mettez le à la télé où il est
intervenu avec une arrière-pensée
mais c'est vrai aussi que le fait
d'empêcher un représentant qui fait 15%
d'apparaître c'est pas très normal non
plus donc la discussion et après il ya
ce intentionnel après ils veulent la
proportionnelle
mais là aussi mitterrand je peux prendre
sa place
mais mitterrand disait mais la gauche
très clame depuis 1945 la
proportionnelle je la fais en gueule
alors ça veut dire quoi
c'est bien aussi que s'il y avait une
part de tactique il voulait amortir la
défaite de la gauche en 86 et faire en
sorte que la droite ne soit pas majorées
ultra majoritaire à l'assemblée pour
pouvoir manoeuvrer comme commis dit il
n'est pas inquiet il est pas interdit
d'être habile en politique ce qui est
d'ailleurs ce calcul de familles de se
faire réélire en 88 donc le vent et
c'est vrai aussi que sans lui et sans
sept à huit il faut faut le reconnaître
la gauche n'aurait probablement jamais
gagné une élection présidentielle
régionales toujours on va dans le nord
cette fois eric dupond moretti qui lui
est sous le feu des critiques depuis
l'officialisation de sa candidature dans
les hautes france
il sera donc tête de liste dans le
pas-de-calais
et quand certains lui disent qu'il a
peut-être autre chose à faire en tant
que garde des sceaux que d'être en
campagne électorale voilà ce qu'il
répond quand un ministre veut
s'impliquer dans la vie locale on lui en
fait le reproche
quand il ne le fait pas on dit qu'il est
déconnecté est ce qu'il en est un parmi
nous qui peut dire qu edouard philippe
n'a pas été un bon premier ministre
parce qu'il s'était engagé au havre
c'est une escroquerie que de dire aux
gens qu'on va les représenter
j'ai une fois qu'on est élu regardez
d'ailleurs s'agissant de monsieur
bertrand
il s'investit ici dans la région mais il
dit je veux aller à l'elysée peut pas à
la fois être à la région et et et à
l'elysée quant à madame le pen elle
n'est ni dans sa circonscription ni à
l'assemblée nationale doit préférer le
château de saint-cloud où il se sent
bien sans doute un bronze mais jean vu
le contexte est ce que eric
dupond-moretti fait bien de partir en
campagne c'est difficile d'être un
meilleur avocat d'eric dupond-moretti qu
eric dupond-moretti lui-même ce qu'il
faut dire et je pense qu'il l'a très
bien exprimé dans cette intervention
c'est qu'on peut pas à la fois
effectivement reprocher à ce
gouvernement une forme de déconnexion
comme certains se plaisent à le faire et
en même temps reproché à eric
dupond-moretti de vouloir être élu
régional
la réalité c'est que cette région il la
connaît par coeur il est né là bas il
est le fils d'un ouvrier métallurgiste
qui et qui a trahi et dans le nord il
est le fils d'une femme de ménage qui a
travaillé dans le nord il a était le
célèbre avocat lors de l' affaire
d'outreau donc on peut difficilement
reprocher à eric dupond-moretti de
vouloir s'investir sur son territoire il
a fait un choix
au delà même de cette élection régionale
qui est un choix courageux celui d'un
avocat reconnu nationalement de
s'investir et de s'engager en politique
je trouve ça cohérent que cet engagement
politique ne se traduisent pas
uniquement par un ministère mais aussi
par amanda locale je pense que toute
personne qui voit à peu près à quoi
correspond de travail et d'un conseil
régional c'est qu'il n'est pas
impossible d'être des à la voix
conseiller régional c'est-à-dire de
siéger une ou deux fois par mois dans
une assemblée régionale et en même temps
d'assurer son travail de ministre de la
justice alors terrain est limité alors
la réalité c'est quand même que depuis
on peut difficilement dire à eric dupond
moretti qu'il n'a pas fait son travail
de mise de la justice depuis qu'il est
arrivé il a une hausse de budget de 8 %
qui est la plus forte qu'on ait eu
depuis 30 ans il a des investissements
massifs dans les moyens humains et
matériels pour la justice il a des
projets de loi qui arrive et vous
connaissez le personnage je pense que
personne ne doutera qu'il mènera ses
combats à fond laurent joffrin
je comprends son argument parce que je
ne peux pas reprocher à la fois aux
ministres d'être coupé des peuples
puissent se présenter à une élection
la difficulté c'est de faire les deux
ensuite si jamais ils gagnent et
qu'est-ce qui va ferrailler choisi voyez
pas candidat à la présidence de la
région simplement un siège de conseiller
régional
oui mais vous voyez ce que vous dites
une fois par mois ou deux les siéges et
donc c'est un monsieur vous avez dû vous
savez bien que quand on a interdit le
cumul des mandats est ce que c'est la
majorité précédente et qui était je
pense une bonne mesure ce qu'on a
interdit c'est le cumul de fonctions
exécutives ne dis pas que c'est lui qui
prenait beaucoup de temps dans l'esprit
ce soit les cinquièmes du sens d'avoir
un ancrage local qui se traduit par la
confiance des électeurs à un moment je
ne le conteste pas c'est ce qui me gêne
un peu dans le chai moretti je comprends
ils attaquent de manière extrêmement le
dur
le rassemblement national donc c'est
très bien mais je crois que ce soit un
peu comment dire
par calcul non non et c'est sincère il
ya pas de doute mais juste que je crois
que ce soit un peu grossier c'est à dire
que ferait on lui dit mais le front
national propose rien mais de vraies
excuses c'est pas moi il propose des
choses horribles
d'accord il propose des choses n'ont pas
nié qu'il proposerait sicile et en débat
avec quiconque du front national le team
de lui sortir ou lahm va lui sortir 22
propositions toutes plus horribles les
unes que les autres mais mais c'est pas
comme ça qu'on fait et enfin à moins
d'être d'utiliser des arguments
populistes contre les populismes mais je
me suis dit il fait mal et un finnois
rase campagne comme j'en sais rien oui
je trouve ça un peu
quand on dire un peu grossier ou un peu
fruste comme argumentation
dans les propos d'eric du monde du
primorie dit au delà de la critique du
fond de ce que propose le rassemblement
national il ya la critique de de ce
qu'est le rassemblement national et de
la façon dont il se nourrit du désespoir
de certains électeurs c'est parce que
vous dites il ya des propositions au
rassemblement national oui il y en a
sûrement mais le problème c'est qu'elles
changent d'élection en élection qu'elle
ne sont jamais les mêmes
regardez la position de marine le pen
sur la dette qui évoluent au fur et à
mesure en fonction de ça qu'il faut dire
l'électorat donc on pas dit rien il faut
dire ça tient pas debout votre affaire
mais c'est ce qu'il dit aussi je pense
qu'il ya une façon vers oui je me
retiens rien de son les deux sont faites
par par cette majorité en tout cas eric
dupond-moretti var au combat avec ses
tripes et je pense que c'est aussi ça
qu'il faut donner la sensation et
l'impression qu'on a des gens qui
s'engagent pour des territoires et pas
simplement des gens qui s'engagent pour
des places mais la droite a une autre
interprétation la stratégie dans marche
christian jacob l'a aussi analysé
toujours dans cette interview du
parisien dont on va voir un extrait la
présence très médiatisé d'eric
dupond-moretti n'est t'elle pas là pour
focaliser les débats sur le rn plutôt
que sur les projets régionaux et donc
par conséquent pour augmenter les
suffrages en direction du rn que pensez
vous de cette interprétation monter les
suffrages ça me paraît un peu biscornue
ce qui est vrai c'est que toute la
tactique dans marché de se présenter
comme l'alternative aura changement
national puisque
ça peut changer du jour au lendemain
mais pour l'instant au deuxième tour il
ya macron le pen donc et pour convaincre
des électeurs hésitants macro on va dire
c'est moi le rend pas mon avis c'est un
rempart friable mais pour l'instant je
l'avais sondage constate
qu'effectivement il est au deuxième tour
et donc il a intérêt ça c'est cette une
j'ai pas si c'est fait vraiment exprès
mais macron il procède par destruction
de l'adversaire y est très habile pour
faire savoir ce que tu es la gauche est
en miettes les pilotes à des élèves la
droite va un peu mieux mais pas terrible
donc on détruit les partis de
gouvernement
et après on se retrouve en tête à tête
avec le rassemblement national
c'est dangereux parce que là vous avez
vu les sondages là aussi eu leur 10e
sondages vont changer un an après c'est
pas très significatif mais quand même
vous vous retrouvez avec lui avec une
marine le pen il sait qu'ils étaient 48%
dans certains sondages et bien une
contre certains candidats
enfin on n'a jamais vu ça en france mais
jamais vu ça et donc le risque réelle
maintenant
et donc cette idée les autres partis
sont un gaou son on ne compte pas et c
est on est on est en en fait sa tête à
tête en face à face comme chien de
faïence
sur la cheminée avec leur assemblée
nationale mais les gens vont se dire
mais finalement il n'y a qu'une seule
alternative en france soit c'est soit
c'est le pouvoir actuel soit c'est
marine le pen ça c'est dangereux
d'abord pour vous répondre sur ce point
je trouve toujours ça intéressant de
dire qu emmanuel macron à fracturer les
autres partis politiques mais la réalité
c'est que moi j'étais où j'ai été
adhérent du parti socialiste pendant
deux ans j'ai rejoint emmanuel macron
parce que j'avais la sensation d'avoir
plus de points communs avec les
personnalités qui ont rejoint emmanuel
macron avec ce qu'il incarnait qu'avec
certaines personnalités qui étaient à la
gauche du parti socialiste et qui ne
proposait rien qui ne me convenaient est
aujourd'hui en fait ce qui s'est passé
en 2010 tête c'est simplement que on a
constaté que les fractures internes à la
fois à la droite mais aussi à la gauche
était beaucoup plus forte
beaucoup plus puissante que les que
l'homogénéité des partis qui voulaient
bien affichée de l'autodestruction est
en germe
mais en fait c'est ça je ne crois pas qu
emmanuel macron
pour volonté de détruire ces partis
politiques ils se sont détruits parce
qu'il y avait à l'intérieur de cette
partie des incohérences fondamental
qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui à gauche vous
le savez sans doute mieux que moi mais
sur la laïcité il ya des divergences
facilement - vous me direz qu elle
existe aussi dans la majorité sur
l'union sur la question de l'union
européenne par exemple entre jean luc
mélenchon et où joue contre sur sur la
vision d'une sur la question du
nucléaire sur les greens de la sécurité
il ya plein de sujets sur lesquels la
gauche est profondément divisée sur
l'économie aussi sur la façon de gérer
donc il ya plein de sujets sur lesquels
les partis politiques étaient
profondément devises et emmanuel macron
il a proposé une offre claire avec des
thématiques claire des positionnement
clair que les français ont choisi de
rejoindre le front national
il a été placé au second tour par qui
part des électeurs en 2017 qui n'ont pas
jugé le bilan des manuels macro qui ont
jugé le bilan des deux quinquennats
précédent et donc dire qu emmanuel
macron et celui qui nourrit le front
national
je ne l'acceptent pas parce que la
réalité c'est que qu'est ce qu'on a
trouvé en 2010 est un pays où il y avait
déjà marine le pen au deuxième tour nous
le seul auquel progresse aujourd'hui
c'est un fait dans les sondages en tout
cas je constate quand même personne ne
le dit mais qu'à la fois aux élections
européennes elle a reculé de quelques
dixièmes de points aux élections
régionales son score national est
aujourd'hui plus faible que ce qu'ils
l'étaient en 2015 donc il ya une forme
de catastrophisme travers des sondages
peut-être que la réalité est peut-être
moindre un troisième point analysé avec
vous ce soir c'est la réponse du général
lecointe aux militaires encore actifs
qui en signait donc une deuxième tribune
dans valeurs actuelles le chef
d'état-major des armées les invite à
respecter la neutralité de l'armée et je
le cite le plus raisonnable dit il est
certainement de quitter l'institution
pour pouvoir rendre public en toute
liberté ses idées et ses convictions
c'est donc ce qu'il a écrit dans un
courrier envoyé à tous les soldats et
c'est le dernier épisode donc de cette
affaire deux tribunes avant d'en parler
avec vous sur ce plateau on va en parler
avec jean-daniel les
bienvenue jean daniel vous êtes
directeur délégué chez harris
interactive france merci d'être avec
nous la deuxième tribune compte
aujourd'hui environ deux millions de
visiteurs uniques et la pétition a été
signée par environ 250 mille personnes
est ce que c'est la preuve d'un soutien
des français à ces tribunes de
militaires ou pas c'est la preuve déjà
d'un appareil quand on avait été amené à
demander aux français à l'issue de la
première tribune
si l'on a bien entendu parler les deux
tiers des français en avaient entendu
parler alors ils ne connaissaient pas
forcément la totalité de ce qui était
contenu dans mais le simple fait qu'il
puisse y avoir des militaires qui expose
des éléments et tire on voit justement à
des dimensions qu'il parlait au français
indépendamment de leur émetteur ab
susciter un vrai intérêt
est ce que la france apparaissait comme
étant entièrement willy la réponse était
non est ce qu'il y avait des
interrogations de la part de la société
française sur la manière dont les gilets
jaunes avaient trade était traitée la
réponse est oui
est ce qu'il y avait eu le sentiment que
certains quartiers et d'élite
inaccessible aujourd'hui aux forces de
l'ordre la réponse est oui donc dans ce
contexte là le simple fait qu'il puisse
y avoir les missions d'un constaté d'un
constat que vivre un stand de français
avait suscité un intérêt sans qu'ils
aient forcément la perception qu'il
s'agissait d'un appel à une forme d'un
soumission ou un appel à la guerre
civile et donc on est dans cette sorte
de continuum avec peut-être une petite
part de mystère c'est à dire que
derrière l'altaïr la signature ou
l'anonymat des français qui demandent
quelle est véritablement cette tribune
qu'est-il entre six mois et fille dans
le cas de ces tribunes et puis avec des
mobilisations part de l'ensemble de la
population française mais de france
populations qui sont sensibles à ces
dematic lors qu'ils sont pour faire vite
le public type lecteur de malheurs
actuels des électeurs qui situe à droite
ou très à droite sur l'échiquier
politique et les personnes qui vont
considérer d'une manière générale qui
emmanuel macron n'est pas à la hauteur
de ses responsabilités notamment à terme
de matières d'ordre l'exécutif condamne
le général lecointe recadre on vient de
le voir est ce que ça pourrait être de
nature à convaincre les français que
l'armée doit rester neutre ou est-ce
qu'au contraire les français en ont
marre de la neutralité et veulent des
positions fortes des prises de position
fortes
il ya un peu pas forcément le sentiment
aujourd'hui que s'il devait y avoir non
pas neutralité de l'armée mes prises de
position de la part de certains membres
de l'armée qu'on saurait face à une
remise en cause fondamentale de ce que
peut être les tenants de la société
française c'est à dire que quand on
demande aux français il n'ya pas la
perception qu'on est face à une armée
qui n'est pas une armée républicaine
on n'a pas l'impression qu'on est à la
veille d'un putsch ou d'un pseudo putsch
comme on a pu le voir de sela par
exemple au moment de la guerre d'algérie
est plutôt le sentiment que de la part
de personnes qui représente l'autorité
une interrogation c'est la matière de
notoriété dans la société française je
pense qu'il faut rappeler deux choses le
premier aspect c'est que la thématique
de la sécurité croît de manière de plus
en plus forte dans la société française
et que à tort ou à raison il ya la
perception que dans le cadre de sa
campagne présidentielle
emmanuel macron n'a que très peu parlé
des dimension régalienne et et notamment
du rapport à l'armée sa salle il y avait
à l'armée et à l'auto a été ça c'est une
première et c'est le deuxième aspect on
a pu voir également que certaines
personnalités emblématiques ont pu
prendre la parole au cours des années
passées
rpi râle un sentiment fort de la part de
nos compatriotes on va parler notamment
du général des milliers qui a à travers
ses écrits a trait à ses prises de
position créer un élan d'opinion
relativement fort qui a fait que même
certains se sont demandés s'il ne
pourrait pas être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle je pense qu'il faut pas
se méprendre
on n'est pas dans une situation les
français vont dire nous soutenons une
possible insurrection ou une possible
guerre civile qui existerait dans la
cité française
en revanche il y à un appel à plus de
fermes des plus d'autorité plus de
régalien et plus de maintien de l'ordre
dans la société française notamment dans
les quartiers qui sont sujets à troubles
poursuit les charges en plateau vous
restez avec nous jean daniel laurent
joffrin il faut rétablir la vérité sur
le premier rappel deuxième je ne sais
pas ce que c'est les années mais c'est
impossible de savoir qui a signé en
revanche le premier quand on a regardé
et qu'ils avaient
square promu l'appel soit soit signé ils
sont tous extrêmement pas tous les pages
parle pas des signataires mais tout ce
qu'on a dans tranquility ont pris des
positions publiques donc se passe il
suffit leur mais ça n'enlève rien d'elle
les coups qu'ils ont oui ça enlève rien
sauf que c'est une magnifique opération
du rassemblement national pour vous
c'est clair c'est évident d'ailleurs qui
a qui approuvait marine le pen eric
zemmour ménard enfin c'est toujours les
même quand c'est mon frère je suppose
par exemple un écho dans le pays
ça correspond à la force du front
national le fin du rassemblement
national et ça correspond aux sondages
et voilà il ya deux cent cinquante mille
personnes qui kisembo il fait combien
500000 quand il passe à la télé face à
me surprend moyennement et en même temps
c'est je trouve ça très inquiétants
parce que ça montre que le balancier
électoral est en train d'aller vers le
haut et donc ça c'est très inquiétant et
je me demande si le march sera assez
assez fort pour être le la digue contre
cette marée la maison ce qui est
intéressant dans cette tribu
n'effectuant que la deuxième c'est
effectivement cette histoire d'anonymat
fin c'est la première chose que moi j'ai
relevé c'est con quand on publie une
tribune de manière anonyme c'est qu'on
ne publie pas une tribune et on peut
s'interroger sur la responsabilité et de
valeurs actuelles publié un texte qui
est signé par personne c'est le premier
point le deuxième point sur sur les
constats qui sont fait effectivement je
rejoins ce que disait laurent joffrin
sur fait que ce soit partagé par une
partie des électeurs de manière très
classique et ce que dit jean daniel lévy
aussi après la question c'est quand même
de savoir quelle est la réalité des
faits sur les sujets régaliens
vous disiez à l'instant que
potentiellement les électeurs n'avaient
pas perçu le côté régalien emmanuel
macron mais la réalité c'est que la loi
de programmation militaire qui a été
adopté dans ce quinquennat c'est une loi
de programmation militaire qui est
extrêmement ambitieuse avec une hausse
de 25% par rapport du budget par rapport
à la loi précédente avec rien que cette
année par exemple 27000 recrutements
dans l'armée
et vous allez voir aujourd'hui les
militaires sur le terrain le travail que
fait florence parly est reconnu par tous
parce que on a doté l'armée à la suite
du travail qui avait fait jean yves le
drian dans le quinquennat précédent de
moyens conséquents
là où la droite jeu
demande qui était au pouvoir entre 2007
et 2012 avaient failli là dessus hervé
morin qui donne beaucoup de leçons
souvent sur ces sujets c'est lui qui
était l'auteur d'une note programmation
militaire avec une baisse de 2 milliards
par an du budget de l'armée
ça c'est sur l'armée et sur la sécurité
c'est pareil les recrutements n'ont pas
cessé depuis le début de ce quinquennat
donc la question c'est même pas tant
est-ce qu'on fait suffisamment sur le
plan des mesures parce que on a une
politique extrêmement ambitieuse à la
fois en faveur de la sécurité mais
surtout en faveur du de la qualité de
travail qui peut être celle de l'armée
ou des forces de l'ordre avec le
renouvellement du matériel des
personnels des bâtiments mais c'est
surtout comment est ce qu'on est capable
de faire transparaître cette action dans
la réalité montré que cette action elle
s'incarne aujourd'hui au plus près de ce
que vivent les gens et là pour le coup
on n'a pas encore réussi et jean-daniel
voulait conclure en quelques mots les
questions en fait n'est pas une
dimension objective d'une dimension
subjective et qu'aujourd'hui on fait
quand on interroge nos compatriotes et
la perception que les manuels maquereau
a mené une campagne présidentielle
autour de l'optimisme autour du retour
de la croissance autour d'une libération
des énergies autour d'une manière
globale d'une forme de confiance qu'il
fallait faire aux individus et de moins
de présence de l'état d'une manière
globale c'est cette situation qui a été
perçu aujourd'hui quand on interroge nos
compatriotes ils disent il faut que
l'état revienne il on nous voit bien à
travers la crise de la commision latent
qui puisse y avoir d'un point de vue
économique
d'un point de vue social mais également
d'un point de vue de sécurité une place
qui se font une place plus importante
accordée à l'est pas et qu'ils n'étaient
pas tout à fait la ligne de crête qui
était portée par le président lorsqu'il
était candidat à la présidentielle merci
beaucoup jean daniel lévy d'avoir
participé à ce match
ce soir merci d'avoir été avec nos
derniers thèmes très politique encore ce
soir l'entretien de jean luc mélenchon
au monde à l'occasion de la sortie de
son livre député du peuple humain un
entretien où il tire à boulet rouge sur
les écologistes les écologistes ont un
avenir aussi longtemps qu'on ne les voit
pas à l'avant dit il et il ajoute ils
ont le label et beaucoup de gens pensent
qu'ils représentent les préoccupations
écologiques de notre époque mais que
dire d'une écologie politique qui
transigent avec les multinationales et
qui méconnaîtraient la nécessité de la
souveraineté du peuple en toute
circonstance le capitalisme écologique
de bonne volonté
ça n'existe pas yannick jadot lui a
répondu ce matin sur lci
j'ai porté un rassemblement très large
vous connaissez mes idées autour d'une
écologie sociale républicaine la
démocratie l'europe
j'ai voulu qu'on explore sa mois pour
sortir y compris des invectives jean luc
mélenchon choisi de retourner dans les
invectives dans la division dans la
brutalisation du débat public
je ne rejoindrai pas sur ce terrain là
alors je ferai un mélange entre louis
tapez sur les écologistes et les
socialistes c'est quoi l'argument c'est
que ces deux forces sont trop
conciliante finalement avec l'économie
de marché ces incohérences cas raconte
parce que quand on regarde le programme
de télé fille il n'a pas prévu de se
débarrasser du capitalisme aux usa il ya
des mesures qui sont pas financées mais
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
premier point deuxième point il reproche
donc à ces deux forces qui ont gouverné
d'être trop prudente ou promole mais
qu'est ce qu'il a fait mais l'entente
lui qu'est ce que la france soumise à
fait pour le peuple
donc il sera clairement permanence rien
mais rien du tout c'est à dire qu'il
comme il n'a jamais gouverné
sauf quand il était socialiste
d'ailleurs c'était un bon ministre de
l'apprentissage en fin de la formation
professionnelle où il a fait des
réformes tout à fait honorable mais
depuis c'est le ministère de la parole
mais qui ne fait rien cela mouche du
coche une fille rien et puis les autres
qui pousse le qui pousse la diligence il
est où ce pays en disant vous avez pas
assez vite ça marche pas en tout cas
l'idée d'une gauche unie s'éloigne de
plus en plus oui mais c'est pas là pour
le coup c'est pas de la faute des
socialistes les écologistes encore les
écologistes disent qu'ils vont avoir
leur propre candidat lorsque l'usap
après c'est pas très unitaire a priori
donc vous tirer un trait sur le deuxième
taux n'ont pas forcément parce que
historiquement la gauche ne gagne pas
forcément quand elle est unie elle ne
perd pas forcément quand elle est
désunie problème c'est qu'il faut être
fort que les vols loin son problème
c'est pas tellement qu'elle est qu'elle
est désunie c'est que son son total de
voix est bas et donc il faut regagner
des électeurs ou est ce qu'on les trouve
les électeurs ne s'est pas à gauche je
pensais que le discours de mélenchon est
incroyable parce que ça consiste à dire
une partie de nos électeurs de gauche
sont partis vers la droite donc il faut
aller plus vers la gauche fait dès
qu'elle est logique de cette affaire est
bizarre c'est avec des civils qu'on fait
les militaires et donc c'est avec des
électeurs qui votent plutôt à droite ou
qu'ils s'abstiennent qu'on peut faire de
nouveaux électeurs de gauche donc cette
attitude sectaire agressive et avec un
programme qui n'est pas financé ça ne
marchera pas et c'est dit
merci à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à ce match des idées ce soir dans rtl
c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouvent lundi à 18 heures et à 22
heures ce sera aussi lundi prochain pour
votre rendez vous quotidiens bonjour
chez vous dès 7h30 au rayonnement de
chimie recevra lundi elisabeth moreno
ministre déléguée chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes de la
diversité et de l'égalité des chances je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée sur
public sénat